hello everyone welcome back to the
corridor cast
today's guest is Phil wang from Wong Fu
Productions now Wong foo I would
describe as if corridor went into
romantic comedies rather than action
films you get wongfuproductions they've
been around longer than we have they've
been a creating stuff since before
YouTube and there's a lot of wisdom it
takes to do something like that in fact
feels kind of become known as a bit of a
an advice guru helping people out with
their love lives in their regular lives
he's also opening a boba shop out of all
things he's a very interesting guy also
a quick reminder for those of you who
were interested in getting the coridor G
ot
GOG EO t-shirt and the iridescent
sweatshirt today as the day of this
podcast going live you have one day to
get them so a reminder for those of you
who have been on the fence and want to
pull that trigger
Jared's reminding me that forgot to
mention the URL corridor digital dot
store to buy the shirts all right guys
let's sit back relax and listen to these
wonderful stories and words of advice
from Phil Wang thanks for coming out I'm
sure man yeah no okay so Wong foo oh
we're going yeah oh man not so awkward
no no I made a product like we're having
such a flowing conversation I'm ready
all right do you want to start Nico well
you know tell us a little bit about
yourself yeah I'm I'm curious and I'm
pretty sure a good majority of the
people watching have no idea who I am
I'm not Freddie Wong that was like Jimmy
yeah Jimmy will be on after you so many
stereotypes that every Asian is probably
just related to each other actually no I
want to hear how would you describe us
to your viewers okay yeah I actually had
to do this like just 20 minutes ago
before you came here
Wong foo is a holder digital if core
digital was focused on like romantic
comedy and a lot more Asian century and
that's that's wrong food to like to a
tea in my opinion that's though you know
a quarter Digital would be if Wong foo
wanted to do more VFX heavy CGI
action comedy and it was a
two white guys no I appreciate that I
think you know nothing stopping you from
doing more romantic based content yeah
you know you know there's the everyone
loves to feel you know everyone watching
right now has fallen in love and has
been heartbroken I don't know maybe
there's something there how do you like
how did you get into focusing on
romantic
okay relationship based let me let me
clarify first of all if you actually go
on our channel we have twice as many
comedies okay
the fact that our brand or identity has
become like this romantic emotional
whatever brand that's actually more on
the viewers really right if you think
about it like if we actually have
produced more just comedy fun lifestyle
stuff but the stuff that sticks with
them that makes them think oh that's
Wong foo that means that we struck
something inside them that makes them
have an emotional connection to us so
they have that feeling that that's what
they want to identify Wong foo as right
so yes we are we try to balance it but I
can't help it if like our number one
video is a 16 minute sad it separates
the content it does yeah and I ocean
yeah and I think that's what so it was
never like a conscious decision of like
oh we need to find our niche you know I
feel like these days like a lot of
youtubers are like oh we got to find
like our thing it was literally just
what I wanted to make like in call I
think I was I'm probably just an
emotional kid I don't know like I grew
up not being loved enough or shown
enough know acceptance or you know
getting enough I love yous from my mom
you know you know supporting me and
paying for college or whatever yeah but
uh but I think you know growing up just
yeah like I I did enjoy love stories I
enjoyed the feeling of of love and
feeling just feeling I loved feeling I
guess right right and so when we started
making stuff yeah like I made
observations about my relationships or
my friends relationships and and got
people gravitated towards that or people
were able to relate as well like to the
way I was translating my thoughts or my
feelings of this particular breakup or
this particular
of you know how I met this you know one
girl or how we you know became friends
or what or being like a nice guy and
being you know ignored and friends right
like these are things that are very like
I said you're very human nation or not
you know like we they're just human
emotions and yeah I guess people just
gravitated towards that and I wouldn't
say that we like try to like exploit
that like you know we actually that's
why we still have mostly comedies
because actually the emotional stuff
does take a little bit longer takes time
we just released a short you need better
actor we just released yeah that that's
true like you need a there's a little
bit more that you need to you know get
out of the the talent but yeah we just
released a short like two weeks ago that
was a script that I was sitting off like
six years because really we're trying to
find the right timing to release this
and yeah it's like a more emotional or a
meaningful one but I'm glad yeah do you
find that observation comes from writing
did that the more you wrote the more you
eat the more you stuck stepped back and
started observing other people um and
what they did I think I think it's a
little bit of that I think it's also and
we say this a lot like you know when we
we talked to like fans that ask how do
you find inspiration like it really is
just like a lens that you choose to see
the world and like I enjoy I you know
have you ever heard of this this thing
called like the the dictionary of you
know sad thoughts are basically like
there's this these made-up words that
are supposed to like mean something like
very abstract thoughts so there's just
there's just like war called sonder
that's like oh like knowing that
everyone you pass by has like their own
story and it's going through their own
struggle and they're okay anyways yeah
so I actually inspiration is everywhere
that's like such a you know like cheesy
saying but it's like you know when you
pass by you know anyone on the street
like they are going through you know
something difficult or something
exciting or something funny and I think
like that that when I know that everyone
has that like that actually really
excites me I guess and like wanting to
find those stories those human stories
that's that's actually like kind of
where I draw inspiration from and I you
know yeah a lot of it is still like from
personal experience I have had you know
my share of heartbreak or heartache
I should say and and I just I feel like
maybe that's like my outlet I can't
write music you know and I I'm not a
good painter but I I enjoy analyzing
emotions I guess and like why we feel
things yeah yeah do any of those stories
like stand out to you things that you
look back under like that that one
emotion or that story around that
emotion like that really speaks to me or
that one really hit like the target I
mean yeah I think I think everyone has
you know that I mean that's like asking
like what's your favorite video like we
always give ask everyone every video has
like a special place but yeah there's a
couple that you know are definitely like
our highest viewed and I'm glad that
people can find something in themselves
in it and I think the best feeling that
I have and when in terms of our videos
is that I love that because we've been
doing this for so long people can now
watch an older video and understand it
differently because it's about
relationships or emotions so when I see
comments we get this lot like oh I
watched this five years ago I watched
seven years ago and I thought I thought
it meant one thing now I'm watching it
like you know in my late 20s and now it
means something completely different and
I I love that our work evolves with
people you know like that it's not just
oh it was there for entertainment at one
place in time which is which is good
like they're like we need videos like
that too but I love that we have some
things that are like oh this is
something that will grow with you as
you're understanding yourself better how
do you develop those layers in a piece I
think it's about being vulnerable and
being uh being just very honest with
yourself I think like there's a lot of
just people in general that like are
afraid to really examine my now we're
getting to like psychology yeah but like
you know like III I definitely allow
myself to I think simmer in thoughts
sometimes more than I think a normal
person like I remember like I had a
friend that used to say fill you you
love love like do you much you know like
and I'm like isn't this what everyone
feels like I think like when I ever
everyone no doubt feels loved and I
think I just like to spend a little bit
more time of like why how did this
happen you know like I like to see
almost like a scientific approach to
these emotions and I think that's that's
where it comes from is that intimidating
to anybody that's dating you
it definitely so I mean my girlfriend
now we we have conversations about it we
have but the thing is I I think I like
to find not I like to Phi as if this
happens but like the people that I end
up with usually are pretty thoughtful
themselves too and I think most most
girls you know like they want their
boyfriends to you know be more
communicative about their emotions so
sometimes I actually feel like I'm too
much and I'm like why am i them let's
try to pull this out of you you know so
many girls are trying to get this out of
their boyfriend you should be lucky so
yeah how do you how do you be vulnerable
online like how do you take these
personal stories and like how can even
bring yourself to put them out there I
think you know what I think nowadays is
it's easier because I know that that's
what people appreciate of us and so when
we first started there was less at stake
you know and we can talk about this this
whole like beginning of YouTube air like
later but like when we first started
there was no expectations of what you
know channel or not or even like an
online personality was supposed to be
that's how old like our Channel and we
are that you know social media wasn't
even a thing yet so we were just
literally like oh this was just fun I
think just as a filmmaker you want to
write a story and like luckily like you
know we had some people watching like so
I guess to answer your question we were
positively reinforced from very early on
our channel to do this I can imagine
yeah like maybe a corridor right now if
you wanted to like make you know a piece
about like you know your your
relationships in the past or that your
audience might be like whoa Nicko
intimidating but I don't I feel like I
feel like people especially nowadays
people appreciate authenticity people
appreciate when they feel like you're
human like them too
you know so nowadays is yeah it's not as
much of a challenge now now now it's it
so it's very rewarding actually to do
that and I and I I'm it's interesting to
hear you ask that question
that I I guess I've gotten so used to
that even you asking that question makes
me like step back and think oh yeah I
guess this is a we're really lucky that
we get to be fully transparent in
ourselves and and not be judged for it
at the same time we do get judged by
people that are like oh Wong foo so
cheesy Wong for what do you guys you
guys are so like you know sappy so and
see those people I'd be like oh you guys
you need to think about your emotions I
feel sorry for you that you can't that
this is too much for you so you know you
have obviously I guess a bunch of videos
or comedy and only some of them are
romantic yeah but even so you're
definitely seen as a little bit of an
authority on this topic mmm you know
looking at yourself now do you feel like
you're an authority on the topic or do
you ever feel like you have like
impostor syndrome yeah because I can
make videos that people watch that's
that I have you asked this question to
other hiatus question of myself okay you
know what I think this is why I actually
feel like I connect with Nikko you know
we don't hang on as much as I think we
should cuz I guess we're both very busy
but I feel like there's like a Midwest
boy in me somewhere so yeah that cool I
don't know I think um I think it's
because we I don't know about you but I
enjoyed making videos when I was younger
there was never a point where I thought
I could do this for a living and I read
stories about like directors now and you
know filmmakers I like oh I wanted to be
a director since you know I was in
kindergarten astronaut is how they
talked about being a director for me
that wasn't that wasn't how it was
because I just thought it was just never
my cards I solved there are so few
examples of Asian people doing it anyway
so I just didn't think that it was even
possible possible route so the fact that
it happened was it did happen kind of I
don't want to say accidentally but we
were definitely at a crossing point of
Technology and opportunity and even
society to like culture being ready for
this shift in how people consume media
right and so luckily I made some videos
in college and we were confident enough
because I was in college and my all of
our suite mates you know we all each
other onto like release things and
high-speed Internet which is just coming
around in college so it was able to
spread in college and then and then it
just kind of went from there but I yeah
I don't think that I didn't calculate
that so nowadays when I'm here
sometimes I'd like like you're asking
like I kind of feel like I have just
been going with the flow and but trying
to make business decisions and choices
to make this flow as as good as possible
because it's a good gig right I'm not we
stressed out all the time but I'll step
back I'm like look no week is the same
you know we get to literally the things
that we thinking or how we get to go
make and people pay for it people
millions of people want to wait to see
the next thing like that's it that's a
blessing right and so yeah I don't feel
like I ever asked for this and so now I
really am just trying to deserve it
mm-hmm because I feel like there's so
many people that want this and like I
don't want to feel like I'm taking it
for granted
but no 100% like I'm just you know
especially in the beginning years when
people like you're a role model you know
you're a voice for Asian Americans I was
like whoa no this is too much like I'm
not that political I'm not that I'm just
a guy that just went to you know UC San
Diego and made some lipstick videos but
now because I were older I understand
that even though I can't explain why I
got here the fact is that we're here and
I need to I need to take advantage is
the wrong word but I need to not waste
this and I need to be responsible with
this voice and hopefully make a positive
impact because I I'm not gonna be able
to do this forever you know like at some
point you know I'm gonna be gone and and
but hopefully like what we the
intangibles can can keep going right and
so that's what I want that's what I'm
more excited about these days actually
like less about like how do I get more
views like I do worry about that
obviously as a business owner or
whatever but it's I think just because
we've been doing this for so long I'm a
little bit removed from the rat race of
like I need to be this personality I
need to be this this thing and it's more
just like how do I just do good with
what we have right you're one of the
rare rare channels I shouldn't even say
channels one of the rare craters it's
not a personality basically per se
doesn't say that your personality isn't
in your work and right in your work
yourself at times but
you're definitely I'm marketing yourself
I'm like hey I'm Phil Wang Chao it's
filming here the Phil wings yeah exactly
yeah and that's and that's what so much
of YouTube is and and relies on and I
get it like because that's how you know
a lot of these channels are one-man
shows that and that's how it starts
but I think true longevity comes from
when you can take your image or your
personality and turn it into a community
or a brand which is why I think I you
know look up two corridors so much and
also relate to you guys so much is
because I mean yeah you Sam you know you
know you know Sammy Nico is a thing but
I mean now your your your crew has you
know over a million subscribers
themselves to you right and like this
brand that you guys are creating you
guys gotta make merch I was well voices
you guys are a big influence in us
getting rich off the ground so we'll get
into Serena's actually but there I just
want to say like there's a phrase that
you use that I really like which was
you're not sure how you got here or
you're not sure if you earned it but now
you're working to deserve it right I
actually really like how you phrase that
cool cool yeah I think and and I and I
get that from you guys too because I
feel like by all measures of what
YouTube success is you guys could have
gone a very different route and not to
say that you guys have made like you
know the wrong choices but I'm glad that
over the years I can still see like oh
this is still the the brand or the the
quality that has like remained the same
and hasn't deteriorated or hasn't
changed too much or being influenced too
much by the scene or the the industry is
as it is right now and yeah and that's a
whole other conversation about YouTube
but yeah well I think there's a question
anybody has to ask himself when they
reach a certain level of success and not
even a high Louis yeah success but just
one we're like it's working the wheels
going around and things are happening
like okay cool so you know you made it
work yeah the question have to ask
yourself is at that point where do my
intentions and if I need to sustain
myself like where do they diverge
because at a certain point you can make
a decision to make more money or you can
make a decision to make something that's
maybe not quite so popular but you can
still support yourself on right but that
might be a little more true to what you
want to do right or message when we put
out there and like it's one thing if the
decisions like if it's like well I could
make a thousand more dollars if I made
this like yeah you know slime Jam or I
could make you know keep doing I'm doing
and maybe make 500 but dollars so maybe
the difference isn't so great but at a
certain point especially once you know
you've been around YouTube long enough
you can see his points where it's like
oh I can make one of these channels and
probably make a million dollars or I
could stick with what I'm doing and just
you know life's good but I'm not making
a million dollars you know and I think
that choice already in itself is is a
huge privilege that we have you know
that's yeah like we the fact that we can
choose between what are we passionate
about versus we need to make money right
now you know like but the the thing is I
don't even like going off to make them
the money like or it's more about like
why are you trying to make that money to
me like if you want to make a million if
you guys wanted to do that slime channel
like I wouldn't judge you guys
necessarily until like a little and this
is this is this is what we do to like
and I know you guys do if you guys were
to do a slime video you would do it in
your way right so like we've done we've
done that too like we've we've hopped on
not hopped on we've we make commentary
on on trendy type videos but we would
make it our way or we would turn into
like a Wong foo type video and I know
that and you guys have done that already
like so anyways but like when we when we
talk to people these days like
especially when do I want to be a
youtuber like how do I like give me
advice I always say like this make sure
like you know what why you want to make
videos like if you want to be a
personality and just get famous and get
a Lamborghini or whatever you're gonna
make certain decisions and make certain
videos fine if that's if that's why you
want to do it sure but just know that
it's gonna be very short-lived it's
gonna be kind of unfulfilled in the long
run but just be aware of that but if you
actually like care about telling stories
reaching people expanding your craft
learning then you should do it that like
because it's this is a hard job like
it's it's very difficult to mean
to start it maintain it so if you have
the right mentality going into it like
if Fame comes with that then that's
great you know but like just know just
hopefully like you're coming into this
this industry with good intentions and
not just like entertainment entry like
that's not the case for a lot of people
some people just want to be famous you
know yeah yeah it's easy to get
attention for sure yeah yeah it's hard
to maintain it's hard to get you know
okay this is also another thing that
with age I think I've learned who's like
there's the there's I feel like the
quality of use is actually way more
beneficial than the quantity of you know
because yeah and I and I remember like I
actually Freddie told me this like or I
dis always stuck with me when he was
doing his video game high school
Kickstarter like you know back in the
day he's like look I have we have you
know millions of subscribers but 10,000
people were willing to give money to
this project I'd rather have these
10,000 forever then you know 10 million
that are just coming coming through or
whatever right so that's that's always
stuck with me
yeah that's honestly that's a huge
difference between our corridor channel
and our corridor crew jam or the
corridor caste channel yeah is that the
a big chunk of the quarter channel is
just people walking through the internet
and the winds of viral video on them and
this little bit really oh that's neat is
very the suggested feed yeah yeah but
but you have a net inside whoever passes
through this and comes into the corridor
crew yeah
now we got you you know so yeah like
that then you get the quality viewer
right so even one like there's dips and
subscriber counts would Obama I'm
actually like not that scared and I used
to be a lot more scared because but now
it's like yeah like whoever we end up
with like we know that they're going to
be with there with us for a while you
know and and I think that's more
valuable there's an observation I've
made that maybe you've made it too and
tell me if you agree with this but I
feel like the way the way trends work
perhaps online and this I'd apply to
everything actually but it's it's to me
it's a three-year trend mm-hmm where you
can establish a thing you can make it
work for yourself you can follow through
with it and you have three years until
it's basically done mm-hmm and then you
need to evolve yeah I mean you should I
do you're evolving throughout the entire
process so you're never you know yeah
but I think like you know anybody who's
like blowing up doing a certain thing
like let's say if some guy gets famous
for juggling so
yeah it's super famous every loves it
he's got three years before it you
better be learning how but with our
content like you know we try to evolve
every year with our content it basically
it's funny because like we kind of have
a set time for it which is December and
January and going into February at least
for the quarter crew channel that's when
we evolve oh and we last year we were
very public with like we're not gonna do
the traditional vlog thing anymore and
try to make it more of a show yeah you
know we tried a bunch of different
things and it's wonky and we finally
settled into it like around you know
March yeah but but you you commit to an
idea and then you see it through and
then you force yourself to reevaluate
and make adjustment yeah that's that I
mean a lot of youtubers are really
afraid to do that or they don't have a
system in place or they don't have the
leadership to make that happen also yeah
so I think that's that's so true I think
um yeah I the three year three years is
a good amount of time because that's
also just amount of time for people to
like grow out of things to I think
that's the other thing too doing this
for so long you we have definitely seen
like the effects of just aging of our of
our audience right right we have fans
now that that approached me I like the
groceries or whatever with a stroller
you know and they're like dude I watched
you this whatever and they'll be like
you guys still do this stuff I'm like
yeah you know but it's all good we had
you then right and then yeah some what
some are still keeping up but like it's
just it's it youtubers don't think be
like about the fact that these fans are
going to like you know grow out of their
stuff and unless you give them something
new or exciting to say hey this creator
still developing this they're still
evolving they're gonna be like okay I'm
good like I will watch you and be
nostalgic of you the same way I'm
nostalgic of like spongebob
all the people that are using spongebob
memes they're not still watching right
right they're they're they're just
mythology of like oh like that time
right or I I liken it to UM like a music
actually a lot you know you have you you
have these bands that have their fans
that are just gonna be stuck with them
for Allah for life but it's because of
that particular era
that they made music that was meaningful
or nostalgic to them a lot of people
aren't waiting for the new you know
their new app the new guys listen to the
new ac/dc who's a good band that like
would make sense but you know me like a
lot of people just play roses yeah I
just and if you have if you have a
fraction of your audience that does that
that that's good like they have lasted
through like the test of time but most
people are just gonna want you for that
season of your life right and so you
either need to capture it or you need to
try to evolve yourself like like Michael
Jackson every decade you know was like
we got a different Michael Jackson right
yeah so there's actually someone at
YouTube that told me this like a like a
partner manager but she's like if you
think about like a TV show if a TV show
goes on for six seasons that's a long
healthy successful show that's going
into syndication definite right yeah and
like youtubers a lot of creators
especially if they're like a vlogger or
like a sore juggler you guys need to
make the guy the fourth year of that
what he's doing that decides not to
catch the like a lot of these people
like they're in their sixth season or
whatever sixth season of their Channel
and they're like wait my views are going
down this is YouTube's fault yeah like
like the algorithms not not doing it or
whatever and it's like no it's just like
any show people moved on and you know
what's crazy is that these mainstream
actors that are on these huge TV shows
when their show gets canceled they're
not like studio you change things what
the [ __ ] you know they're like oh I
guess I got to go find another gig crazy
these like these a listers are like I
have to go find another job and you have
YouTube creators right now they're like
no I deserve to be famous forever you
know that's like the entitlement is like
so crazy it's really ridiculous and I'm
like no like you need to push yourself
and give them something new you know
like so that's when people like write
books and stuff my kitchen TV shows yeah
which I think a PewDiePie is a great
example of somebody who is the evolved
is content
to like you know if you think about it
game videos like gaming videos yeah our
old news never when they were like the
hot new thing on YouTube like that was
yeah he brought that whole wave up with
it yeah it's like he's money in the wave
bunch of those you know markiplier and
jacksepticeye it's like we're playing
video games like you're watching people
play video games wow you know what a
lame thing it's like I was just slowed
up yeah yeah but then like you they're
doing their thing for year 2 and then
vine happened and then vine shut down
and all those Viners came over and that
was the new wave and now the video
gamers were what we were like when the
video gamers came onto youtube oh
there's a new hot thing and we're not it
dude I think like that moment for like a
lot of popular kids is like a very
humbling moment when they realize oh
wait there's other the fans are like I
have fans but like they're gonna go like
they can go to someone else like what
like I thought you were for me only you
know like there's no talented people
being born and growing up entering the
industry oh no exact like new ages that
are growing into the age of consumption
that want that you are actually the
old-school one you know like like it's
it's david dobrik i have not it's it's
basically like a almost like a vine
compilation' but it's done in a vlog and
there's hard cuts to different scenes
and it's just manic screaming like his
friends doing just the Paul brothers
dudes like so much it's so much more raw
than that like even the Paul Brothers
videos have edit this is literally like
hard cut on a phone like you edit it
with a phone and uploaded it it's yeah
that's the dream guys that's like but
that's the equivalent that's today's
equivalent right there you know for sure
for sure so wild yeah I mean I don't
know like I think you know for us we've
been doing this for 15 years if you want
if you count our first video in college
which is if you do the math before
YouTube started yes we were we bought
server space that we used
access to an FTP what do you even call
an FTP yeah yeah had a had a domain as a
website that had a link that people had
to right click and download a file that
we would send that link and put in
people's buddy lists on AIM download the
file and watch it on a media player like
that sentence is just oh
video 3 or was it like Windows Media
Video yeah I was widowed so I on
pinnacle ok took like four or something
I don't know
on my Dell and and this is crazy that to
see how much it's it's changed and
evolved for like like hey my buddies
downloaded a bunch of Internet videos
you want to come over and watch him go
back to those Ebaum's days man yeah
Raycom actually just recently met
someone that was like oh yeah I was like
the VP of whatever at break calm like
back in the damn light oh my god
so going back to this stepping into this
I guess advice roll at what point did
you start to feel comfortable with it
you know at what point was it about it I
think like that's a good question I I
think once I realized that I was
significantly older than people and that
actually did have more life experience
than a lot of people that were asking
for it but I'm not saying I'm like the
Guru like you know but like for a lot of
people asking me like when I started to
see like oh I actually can't help you
because I actually do have some insight
on this I think that is the moment that
kind of made me lean into it more yeah
and also when I kind of like look to my
left and right and I realized that oh
not a lot of other creators or youtubers
or asian-american you know creators are
trying to help you know in the same way
so I was like you know I don't want this
to be a void and I don't want I don't
want it's not that I saw like a moment
to pounce on I was like oh right someone
should help and speak on this stuff you
know and if people want to know like I
don't want I don't want it to be like I
had an opportunity to help and I didn't
you know
right um so do you feel like that came
with a sense of responsibility - Oh
totally yeah I feel like I mean
literally like when we have q and A's
people like ask like relationship
questions sometimes or or like a life
advice or career advice and I'm like a
man
everyone's going through so I'd have to
have a sit-down life coach conversation
like I like but um for sure you pursue
your passions and don't give up you know
but I mean like I I am very careful I
actually like in general with our
content these days we are very sensitive
about like what we put out there like we
try to make sure that we're we look at
the content or the story or the
characters or the casting from a very
360 perspective and like it it kind of
sucks that we have to do that and I
don't mean that in like a like it's such
a chore but it's like the fact that we
will gets judged so hard you know on
like little decisions of the story or
things like that kind of a can you give
me a can you give us an example I mean
for example like I mean even just
casting like a person in the video okay
like we have to think about should they
be Asian or not you know like it's like
we can't we can't just have like a
default like yeah they should be Asian
because that's just who I imagine
because here's the thing like if we put
someone as Asian as a lead we know that
there's going to be a large oh the
people generally will glance on me like
oh this might be this must be like an
Asian thing right like the default is
not to think that oh this is just a
video that is just a video like it would
be like oh is this an Asian thing first
it doesn't help that our name is Wong Fu
Productions I'll be the first to admit
that but then like so like you know if
we want to be more you know I guess if
we want to be people people think that
we pigeon horror cells as as Asians like
oh you guys only cast Asians which is
not true but like we do want to give
opportunities to Asian American actors
and so if we do that people some people
will say oh you guys need to like open
up your you know open up your group more
and have more diversity it's funny like
white people are the diversity but then
if we do that we also have a large
proportion of artists that would be like
man you guys sold out you guys are
supposed to represent us and
why would you why would you do this just
lets us tell our stories you know like
so even something as simple as like who
do we put as the lead is already some
that we have to like conscious
consciously say this one's going to be
this so what do you what do you do in
the person being the person that's
making that decision how do you make
that decision so so these days like I'm
these days I'm like pretty unapologetic
about like the we will always have at
least I think one lead that's Asian
American that's just because of we want
to give those opportunities since they
don't have as much out there and so if
people want to give us a hard time about
it like that's another thing too like we
know that there are Wong foo haters out
there and like at the end of the day
it's like you know we're actually trying
to make a difference and a lot of haters
in general are not right so if you don't
like what we're doing then you should go
make it yourself right and not in an
arrogant way but like literally haters
go make things you know and then you can
you can be part of the conversation be
the change in the world right exactly
exactly I mean I don't want to get into
it but like there's even like even like
because we stole like a lot of romantic
stories right so even like like what
pairing of races that we have to like
that's something that like we have to be
sensitive to because there's different
perspectives in the community like you
know what's acceptable or what's
offensive or whatnot and it's just like
oh man I wish we could just like not
think about this you know that we could
just be accepted for just putting
ourselves as we are you know like you
just decide that a certain point and
just go you know what this is how I feel
about this role and these characters and
how they would interact so this is what
I'm gonna make it yeah generally it's
about that we still do we want to
definitely also be conscious that you
know the world is diverse and we do want
to reflect that as well but at the same
time you know I actually take a lot of
like notes from like the
african-american like entertainment
community like they have like a lot of
great films where they're just
unapologetically like yeah this is just
a group of you know african-american
friends and like they don't have to
explain why you know and and same thing
like there's tons of movies that are
just like a group of white people it's
like and they don't have to explain why
I wish we could get to a point where we
can choose to do that or not do that and
not explain why you know and that gets
really dicey like I I mean we we want to
if we're asking for inclusion we should
be inclusive
about the same time we're trying to
balance trying to give ourselves you
know opportunities as well so that's see
this is all the stuff that were to think
about before week's comic has something
you know totally and there's different
expectations from you know the fans ya
know like and what what they think that
you know we should we should do yeah we
have some very hardcore fans not not on
the racial stuff I didn't like if we
step away outside of filmmaking
mmm-hmm people will some people will oh
you guys have changed like old videos
now what is this this doesn't feel like
any work was put into this man dude yeah
everyone everyone like that's that's
another thing like doing this for a long
time you realize you can't please
everyone and people only know what they
don't want yeah no one knows what they
love it then they realize oh yeah that's
what I wanted but they will own the only
no like I don't like that you know like
so yeah I think that you guys have just
had to be or we all have to just be
honest with what we want to make that's
like we're in the driver's seat right
and obviously be conscious of you know
of you know how our content affects
people but you know you can only do that
to a certain point before you or
completely like just you know pandering
yeah then you're just pandering to
everybody that has a complaint exactly
exactly and it helped anything exactly
right I think that the ultimate at least
one ultimate challenges I see with
representing diversity and videos or I
guess really in anything but you know
for us it's videos yeah I do right is
you kind of have two options and one is
like do you focus on race and ethnicity
to represent diversity yeah in one hand
you're representing diversity but you're
also now focusing on race and do so or
do you not focus on race and ethnicity
which has its own merits but at the same
time you end up sometimes not having as
much done be that and so it's like they
both can have like noble pursuits but
they can both have right bad causes
because of that or vice versa well I
would say this just to this is a value
of some of that concern like the fact
that you're even aware of that he's
already like what a lot of people don't
even mmm they don't gonna take that step
right so if you take that first step of
thinking about it like then that's
already what more than like 99% of like
Halle was probably doing I mean I I
agree like I think
at least from my perspective there's say
it's exactly like those two because like
in terms of like wanting to be seen and
feel like we're accepted there's there's
two ways to present Asians or diversity
right it's like you paint it red and you
can and now you can educate people now
you can say this is what makes us
different but also the same like for
example like a show like fresh off the
boat or whatever where it's like this is
clearly you know we're going to bring
you into our world right or you do it
like what you said where it's like we
don't even draw attention to it and it's
just a character and they're human and
this is just a family or this is just a
group of friends and that has its both
actually have both actually have
benefits I think to push the message
forward I don't think I think once you
try to choose one or the other that's
when that's when you actually have like
a disagreement action between like it's
literally two like ways of thinking from
like the community where it's like which
is actually the best one I actually
think it's it's it's a case-by-case
situation depending on the story of the
project yeah yeah yeah has this most
things in life it depends what this era
right now like everyone wants to have a
200 480 character tweet where it's like
this is definitive yeah is this black or
is this white exactly well there was
that one shade of light I got in there
no it's great it's dark grey so it's
definitely black yeah bright light
insolence
sorry I'm going wait you mentioned you
own a coffee shop do you want a coffee
shop I'm in I technically do right now
it's not grand open by the time this
comes out it will be open I mean are you
leaving no I I've always just had this
passion for having a brick and mortar
it's a boba coffee shop so like it's
it's it's tea milk tea boba and also we
have espresso coffee that's all yeah and
I think there's I mean I think it's um
it's something I've always wanted to do
so just to take you back through so yes
I am tickled by the story yeah you know
they teach in the film school you know
you you make videos and you go sell
coffee like that's
that's what you gotta open a restaurant
in the in-between you sell stuffed
animals like we did right actually
merchandising should be a very important
course that they teach in film school
buddy now it should be yeah I mean
that's what that's why we had Star Wars
um so I think so basically when I was
growing up in high school
boba milk tea are you guys familiar with
boba milk so I if I feel like it was
just coming to the States and by the
states like I think just like California
cuz it was like the closest thing from
Asia so I remember growing up and first
being introduced it introduced to it a
thing you like oh this is so obviously
it's really good it's a unique but then
also it gave me like a sense of pride
like I feel like um you know growing up
as minority or like we as a first
generation we don't agen Americans most
of the people here have are like first
generation so there's actually no
established Asian American culture and
so we actually had to adopt and take on
other people's cultures and that's why
you know I listen to hip-hop and R&B but
then I also listen to blink-182 and like
you know went through like a alternative
phase you know like we we took from
other people's right which which makes
sense in the soy fund that's the beauty
of America but boba was like the first
thing that was like oh this is like from
like my culture and it's here now and
like I feel like this is cool and like
I'm accepted and where did it originate
it's like like Taiwan China like it's
from like yeah like East Asia but that
definitely like if that's that's gonna
be a dicey question there so I almost
saw it as like it was like our barber
shop you know like it was like a place
really I felt accepted and they played
like you know Chinese music and anyways
and so I thought it was cool
when I went to college I went I've
worked at a boba shop you know to you
know just make it with some extra money
and I felt the community I love people
watching I love feeling like I was a
bartender or whatever and then when I
moved to LA I actually got a lot of like
worked on at boba shops because like I
feel like a lot of like cafes like let's
say like a Starbucks or like a
traditional like American coffee shop is
you get espresso and you maybe get like
a pastry but like at these places you
can get like a me
with the drink and you can sit there
there's Wi-Fi so like I enjoyed that
whole process and wrote a lot of scripts
you know like at boba shops and I'm like
I want I want one of these for myself
you know like as as um you know
Wang Fu's grown I've just it's just it
was always something that was like
sticking or like that's something I I
always joke like when I long food goes
away I'll just be sweeping up my bobo
cafe you know selling milk tea
but yeah like kind of like things online
where I found like a business partner
that was also in between some you know
of his career and he's always wanted to
go into hospitality and and and culinary
like you know arts and so we linked up
on this and I even joked I'm like hey
Eric Eric is his name also last name
wing doesn't support the whole joke that
all agents are related but way is the
second most popular last name in the
world does really it's hard to avoid
that it's Lee and then wing oh I le II
I'm guessing but that's because there's
a lot of like you know non agent Lee's
too so that probably is what helps them
cause that's the Anglicans spelling of
it so maybe yeah yeah there's so many
now yeah
so I joked with him I'm like look I'm
only getting less popular you know
whatever whatever I'm making every year
depends but like as of right now like
day-to-day I'm only getting less popular
right or like my my social marketing
power is only like diminishing with each
day if I if I stop doing things now
right so let's go make this boba shop so
I can like you know send fans over and
you know we can we can make a business
out of this and it is something I'm
really passionate about so yeah I mean
like I'm I've been working out for like
two years and haven't really told anyone
about it because I didn't never knew
where was going but like we finally got
a spot in October I've been renovating
it and I've been learning so much about
88 compliance and learn so much about
like materials and finishes and we you
know like working with like a design
firm and everything like it's been a
really cool experience and we had a soft
opening and genuine seeing people come
in and
you know a lot of them obviously being
you know fans of Wong Fu also like it's
it's so cool that now I have like a
place a public place that embodies or
that can bring people together for that
did you did you have to get a loan or
did you know so we found we found
investors for it and luckily that's its
people it's a lot of it was friends and
family but like the it was so people
that believed and they've seen what
we've done with Wong foo or what I've
done with Wong foo and they're like okay
you seem like you work pretty hard and
you're probably not gonna waste this you
know like so and we weren't like raising
that much but um you know we have yet we
have a group of investors and a lot of
them were just like I just want to
support your dream you know and and I
know you're not gonna lose this yeah so
yeah yeah you know takes a long time to
get that credit huh do a special recipe
Oh a signature drink yeah we have we
have one that Eric is really proud of
that he made up it's a carrot juice
matcha milk tea oh so it's like this
very sweet the sweetness that and like
that it's like a healthy feeling like
boat the boat was actually pretty
healthy there's like a [ __ ] I
would you like it's like a real you know
a real real milk to you like we we're
different from other places like we you
know we we use you know real milk like a
lot of places just use Cramer's we use
real fruit a lot please people just use
service but yeah so we're trying to like
make this kind of like fusion of things
the way that I describe like our we have
food also it's like a mix of the things
that like my mom made at home versus the
things I ate I like my school cafeteria
like that's to me that's like the Asian
American experience where like I had I
had what I ate you know from my mom's
cooking but then I also really wanted
tater tots you know like yeah and so
like I would come home and like I would
be mad that mom like mom I just want
pizza at school you know and then but
then like now like now that I don't live
at home I'm missing my mom's you know
traditional cooking so it's like kind of
fusing these things together okay yeah
and it's called bopomofo cafe mo fo and
they see po po mofo technically so um
are the first like symbols of like the
the mandarin alphabet no no they don't
teach it anymore like now it's like the
now it's like pinyin like it's all yeah
it's like the what do you normally see
like with like a Roman Roma side
romanticise romanticise or sorry just
like
like letters like yeah yeah romanticize
letters yeah yeah okay yeah ha Popo mofo
it doesn't stand for like boba no no
it's all we're trying to say that's like
the tongue in cheek yeah I think so
but now we're like really old man on
YouTube oh my god we should have cans
and like white beards and stuff like
that yeah how are you guys actually like
I'm gonna flip on you how are you have
any of your guess as Nico Jake how are
you guys doing there's so many like you
know cheap VFX these days are so easy to
find how this cheap via fan you know
there's everyone's doing games action
how do you guys how have you guys
remained growing and still on top of
your game oh man I'm actually curious
roll of this pot yeah it's just like the
jacket welcome to hit by a semi-truck
interview questions um we're doing all
right
really good man go do it right you know
the fight thing is like there's a moment
in time we were through the 80th most
subscribed channel on YouTube yeah yeah
we hit you 54 did you Wow we never vote
50 um I hope to be past 80 I think we
got to 78 didn't we yeah but now you
guys are more subscribers than us so
congratulation thanks or are we like 600
I don't know yeah but like it's the
funny thing is like our views in some
ways are down like we're so small
compared to like a lot of the big
youtube yeah but at the same time
there's some other things that like we
have like we have this history which
lends itself a certain sense of like
credibility that you can't get anywhere
else yes
and then even though our views aren't
huge the views that we do have like you
know you guys watching it's the people
that watch us have watched us for a long
time and I think we we really appreciate
the people that watch us we try to make
content that those people appreciate and
in turn I think those people really
appreciate it so we have this like we
have
this audience of people that I think
really connect with our material and
these people the people then inspire us
to continue making this material and
like you don't need to have 10 million
people watching your stuff as long as
you have some people watching your stuff
passionate about it that drives you as
an artist well for the record you do
have 10 million people watching certain
videos certain videos is true yes it's
nice to have it's nice to remind
yourself every once in a while you can
make a viral hit right because I don't
think if you you can't break a million
views once in a while on YouTube then
you're gonna struggle a little bit but
uh I think the big the big challenge
that we face and this is cameras going
with my question to you all so it's like
it is a creative industry and it is you
have to be creative you have to talk
about things that people are passionate
about you have to showcase passion in
your work it's one thing to be
passionate about your channel two years
into it when the views are blowing up
and you hit an 80th on your subscriber
tube
it's another thing to be passionate
about it 10 years down the line when
you've made all your videos that you
kind of had your ideas for and now like
what do you have to say to the world
like what can you bring out there what
can get it's new and I think that is a
struggle um there are times when you
struggle with it and sometimes you know
the solution is just like make something
dumb screw it yeah not think about it
too hard there's other times you think
about it really hard and you invest a
lot of money into something you know
it's not necessarily going to be popular
but there are business constraints on
how often you can do that course so I
would say like for me right now like my
passion for like long-form like
television or movies has been killed
just a little bit mm-hmm and I'm sure
that will come back up but it's just
it's been so difficult to like hurt you
I think it's more than like the
challenge of trying to get a big project
off the ground yeah record it's like
it's like trying to get a business loan
for like ten million dollars let me show
a huge amount of like blueprints and
prep work and business plans to do that
and it starts to lose like if you put me
in the director's seat with like a
normal Hollywood crew yeah you lose a
lot of what makes me as a director
special
you know I've kind of come to realize
that also I realized that what I thought
movies were and maybe what they were in
like the 90s and I was going up with
films it's not really what movies are
these days oh yeah and so like that
dream like even if I could go out and
make one of those like that world
doesn't exist anymore yeah so there's
always kind of like catches to that
ideal but at the same time I am sitting
here in my own studio yeah like I would
trade spots with you you know right and
I think it is always greener yeah it's
more about understanding the evolution
of where things have gone in that yeah
I'll never go out there and make like a
terminator - or a true lifestyle film
because those films will never happen
again
yeah but I can invent my own way of
doing that and I can still go out make
kick-ass action films right cool stories
yep I just need to not write it like I'm
James Cameron going to direct t2 I need
to write it like i'm nico from corridor
digital yeah going out to make it a
digital video not even i see a YouTube
video just a digital piece yeah in
understanding that evolution and like
learning to kind of like let go of some
of the old ways and doing things I think
is where I'm at now in the process the
thing is like because there's not just a
set way to do things I don't just have
the answer with like okay here's how me
to do it exactly yeah you can't like
slowly work your way into it but
surrounding all this is really
fulfilling work with working with
everybody in the studio
even if I'm not making or writing a
video yeah I'm still helping guide other
people make and write videos and I'm
seeing just great content come out of
corridor all the time right and that's
super fulfilling yeah I think being able
to see that you're in what you do or
have built is enabling others and you
know even providing livelihoods like
that's it that's that's something that
is definitely rewarding and definitely
and knowing that you're enabling new
ideas and people that wanted to make
stuff like yeah I think like I mean I
don't know I feel like I mean you you
guys have a patreon page too so we
started one as well and I mean that's a
lot that's a whole they were like like a
category of work that that is that needs
to be tended to but like like have you
guys like what like you don't wanted to
make your own indie film yes yes yes but
like because like you guys obviously do
things on a budget
you know we do too you know and but I
eat in like I feel like I feel like your
fans would show up I really do you know
I do too it's just I don't know what it
is but there's something that stops me
from doing like a Kickstarter for a film
oh I don't know what it is I mean I'll
probably do it at some point but I feel
like I just feel like I'd never have the
idea works like this one's the one all
right everybody this is the project that
we've been working on for years please
give us money to make this movie like I
don't feel like I've ever quite hit that
you know that's that sounds like more
like a personal hurdle though because
you have had ideas that have been on
YouTube originals that have been on go
90 like you have bigger ideas that
you've done true right I think that a
challenge with that is that like because
we are still kind of connected to the
industry I feel like we could try to
make it happen without having to rely on
everybody funding our project I totally
agree with you like especially since you
already have patreon it's like hey can
you guys come back again like yeah I see
what you mean like that's kind of where
we're at - were the next indie film that
we make or film whatever
I definitely probably wouldn't crowd
fund it mmm I think we have enough yeah
like you said were adjacent enough close
enough and we also have people that have
shown already shown interest in just
straight-up investing in our in our next
film that we would probably just go that
way and we would take that just bigger
risk off the top you know but I'm I'm
ready and anxious for for the for the
next girl we'll see what happens i think
i think what sam and i realized we had a
discussion about this and brought up
with everybody else here in the CEO
since then is i think the future of
longer form narrative storytelling with
corridor lies in US making effectively
pilots yeah not necessary with the
intention of being a TV show just
straight-up mini movies yes speak where
it's a contained story and then if
somebody wants to like have us make a
show out of it great if not not a
problem because at the end of the day
we're just making it for the people yeah
it's out there for the people the end
that's that's exactly this is this is
why we connect is because that's that's
literally the strategy that we started
implementing and we we did so last year
we made a show called yappi on our
channel it's live it's a five episode
series so it's about actually told a
running time like an hour and a half Wow
and it it came from me actually going
out trying to pitch it as a TV show and
I realized first of all I got passes
a variety of reasons and I was like okay
I could do the shell this like most
riders do they'll show their idea if it
doesn't go or I can try to like change
it to make it more palatable or sellable
but that was like wait we already have
fans that are gonna watch this also even
if even if one of these production
companies did take this idea we probably
would just make a pilot presentation
anyways why don't I just go do that and
then I can bring this back out to market
or I'll have a finished product that you
know I can say like look this is this is
exactly what we were trying to do and
it's less it's easier to pitch I guess
and so we have we made it five episodes
and you know we had you know I think
right now like there's over two and a
half million views on the series and
like that to me is so much is so
fulfilling like yes like we were able to
actually yeah like give an example of
what we wanted to do and then some you
know and and now we're doing with
another thing like so we're investing in
like an in single and like single
projects to to show like a bigger idea
right and I think I think you know
Corridor Wang for whatever we have the
production capabilities that a lot of
other channels wish like they don't have
that the fact that you can even do that
and make your own pilots is what you
know very very few channels are able to
do and I think going back to even what
you're saying about like how the history
and the legacy or whatever of even
though like we don't have the views like
that's what that's why people want to
work with you guys is because they know
that you guys have been able to sustain
that's something that they want to hitch
their wagon to or be associated with
even like when we cast you know a new
talent or new create like you know some
new influence would it be in our stuff
like they have way more views than us
I'm like you guys really want to be in
our thing you know and they're like yeah
you guys won't feel like you know like
whoa like that's such a weird thing to
hear but it's like I think it's because
they know our track record right and I
think that's what you guys you know
possess and and can offer to like a lot
of people I'm even thinking about like
wanting to partner up with other
creators to say what are your pilot
ideas mm-hmm and then it becomes like
this we like now actually we truly are a
production company where people pitch us
their ideas and we go out together or
something like that
and yeah very few few channels are able
to do that yeah yeah I mean that's yeah
it's just minute it's just been a matter
of I think reexamining the medium that
we're working on yeah since since we
started because when we when we started
it was still you know short films or
sorry feature films were indie future
films was still pretty viable at that
point but you know it's just continued
to diminish that market has continued to
diminish and so and and at the same time
we happen to have our ourselves in a
position where the thing that is going
up is digital mm-hmm and it's continued
to do that and I mean people don't even
use that word anymore digital comes from
a quarter feels like oh we shoot them
with digital cameras maybe instead of
quarter productions or films it's a
digital that's that the distinction of
that is even going away at this point
it's becoming so prevalent and so now
it's just a matter of like hey we've got
X amount of subscribers we get X amount
of regular views each month like how can
we make all this work towards new ideas
that push us creatively and you know who
knows like Sam wrote a book yeah we're
releasing that yeah trying pilot some
different concepts and seeing which
one's pop like that's all fun that's all
fair game right now you know what you're
missing though a boba shot apparel store
or airsoft you know facility actually
guys what if you guys could open up a
brick and mortar business mmm what would
that be this Diller II a distillery
which is it like of what like white
whiskey my whiskey and then we'd we'd
barrel it and Oh we'd have we'd have all
kinds I have thought this out I have I I
think this is gonna be something you got
to do well unfortunately I can't speak
too much about it because oh [ __ ]
distilling alcohol without a permit is
illegal oh we're talking about it all
we're talking about it it happen
so if there was a film about Jake
distilling alcohol theoretically yeah
and he's already done it what would it
be like he would be we distill the
alcohol we drink it and then we try to
build a warehouse around it Wow after
having consumed the alcohol I see this I
honestly see this in your view if I can
go so milk tea like you can sell you can
make this decision Sam and I are
actually pretty keen on this idea like
long term do you want to try it all
right all right I'm ready to go to your
grand opening sweet yeah well you were
saying this and the thing I was
listening to that I brought up before
the podcast and that's you were saying
some things are okay to just leave as
hobbies yeah yeah some things right well
that was under the graduation speech
maybe yeah yeah and as a kind of a
downer piece of advice I think so the
reason why I said that is I said this at
the graduation speech so I gave the
commencement speech at UC San Diego in
how did that feel terrifying so I've
done a lot of public speaking but it's
always I know the audience like they're
here see me or whatever or Wong foo that
was the first time I was like there's
people that have no idea who I am they
don't give a [ __ ] about they just want
to see their kid go up and get the good
diploma I'm so I was so nervous there's
5,000 people like it's it wasn't it was
intense which is not that big if you
think about how many people watch your
videos right which is which is actually
testament to be like that's how many
people are watching our videos right
it's all of ours yeah but I think one
thing the longer I do this too and
obviously you know coming across so many
people that try to do what we're doing -
I have recognized that there's a lot of
people because of a variety of reasons
financial familial maybe even like going
even how they were raised there they
will never sorry never the wrong word it
will be extremely hard for them to make
the jump to fully pursue their passion
to chase their dreams and you just like
I don't like actually I don't like the
advice actually of saying hey go pursue
your passion otherwise what are you
doing with your life you know like
because some people just don't have the
ability to do that right so I don't want
the the point of the speech cuz most
graduation speech is always like chase
your dreams you can do it no matter what
it's like some people like no I I have
to pay off my student loans first you
know like that's that's what a lot of
people don't think about so I didn't
want to make a speech that was like
guilt in people to not know their
passion or like why aren't you doing
your dream right now like all these
people especially UC San Diego are going
to like bio or science or something that
is very STEM related right so it's like
I don't I feel like arts and creative
arts are always like you know glorified
it's like oh those are the people I'm
like one time I had someone that was
like do what you doing is so amazing and
this guy was a neurosurgeon right and
I'm like I don't do [ __ ] you have like
nerves in your hips yeah
you're saving someone's life right so
there's definitely like this image of
like oh wow like you pursue your dreams
you're into creative arts that's so cool
and I'm like I don't want to make people
feel lesser if they chose not to do that
and that there still is a lot of pride
in having like you know an honest living
and so for those people I would still
say hey being creative having having
some type of energy or specific
interests is still very important to
just I think mental health and having a
fulfilling life
so yes keep those a hobby you know or
like don't a lot I feel like a lot of
people as they get older that they just
fall into like you know their their
routine of I just work I come home I
watch TV I eat I go see right and like
hey remember when you were a kid a team
gear call or in college right now you
guys about to graduate you liked to do
this you like to dance you like to play
music don't forget about that as you get
older so that's that's kind of what I'm
saying like it's it's really about like
look you're not gonna you're not gonna
drop out of school and go be a drummer
that's not gonna that's on your cards
but you can still be a drummer for your
you know local church or you can you
know help your kids out someday with you
with their band or something you know
like there's there's things that you can
still keep that alive oh yes yeah that's
super important for yeah I think that's
not often spoken of enough like this
this whole thing of like the people that
aren't just making it in the creative
arts as they at threw away everything
else in their life to go pursue it or
what
yeah those people make way more of a
difference on the day-to-day then then
as anybody knows I mean we give people
entertainment and joy sure but you know
when somebody's sick or when somebody
needs real help yeah yeah like you know
that's a physical person there yeah it's
a whole different level right oh I mean
yeah like that's the the people watching
like if they're you know I'm sure
they're all fans of you guys and like
it's so cool it's like I just want
people to like have pride in what
they're or also realize that they still
have a purpose and that they're not just
living life passively like I'm just here
to like watch other people like you can
make an impact at home you know like in
your own small community you know like
don't don't don't take a pass or don't
take a backseat and say that wall I died
I couldn't do it you know so I'm just
like I'm gonna try like you should still
try you know and some to some capacity
yeah and that the mental health of that
gives you the fabric that it gives you
in the candy that you're in all that
stuff is extremely important right now
right and arguably like physically
interacting with people has such a
bigger impact than just like paying at
lip service in a video it's one thing to
say something another thing to actually
take action right somebody right so what
that said move out to LA and apply for a
course that already passed we already
fitting applicants yeah we had a guy
coming in today yeah at to actually go
what I'm so curious what would you open
what would be a business on you and open
maybe a school a school yeah like not
like a high school like a film school or
oh okay actually whenever I sleep I will
watch your guys's like cinema tips how
are they doing things and I might oh
[ __ ]
actually I got a bone to pick with you
guys oh we saw a BTS of you guys
shooting in the woods or something and
and apparently yeah someone on your team
thinks that we have shitty audio at Wong
foo oh really
yeah I did a little research oh yeah
there's an audio problem or something
yeah and they're like let's just do this
or whatever and like he's probably in
like in the audio like you know u2 and
leaning out of the cap you know in here
and yeah see that's what's giving him
the you know the place to say that are I
said yeah you're working with actual you
know boom operators and stop give us a
break man you know there's a story I
think is a be great to tell in this
podcast because I think I think more
people need to hear it if they are fans
of corridor which is way back in the day
like 2010 like in Febuary this is how
old where where I'm like is 8 years ago
back in the day to some people it is I'm
like it's just oh yes we went to so
Sarah Evershed who is Joe pennis wife
she wasn't his wife at the time she's
just getting into like managing
youtubers back then I think it's called
big cloud at the tire is a brain no no
before was a before big friend yeah I
think I think that's a big cloud or like
I forget something like that big frame
was yeah yeah yeah it was after cloud
something she was doing an event for
Olga Kay who had just finished like a
circus-themed video that she was like
premiering it was just a regular YouTube
video BLS but they had a party for it
and I ended up going I'm just some scrub
like fresh from with Scott well fresh
from school in Wisconsin but ya know
from Minnesota moved out to LA like
maybe a year before and we had just
dropped frozen crossing like a few weeks
before that and so we have one video on
the internet
it was our Channel
so has this party like surrounded by
legit people like making things happen
on YouTube and YouTube's not even like a
big thing yet you know like big is like
a hundred thousand subscribers at this
point yeah
and you and the rest of the long food
guys are there and you're like hey
you're the guy that made frozen crossing
I was like ah this guy who's making it
happen on YouTube who's totally legit
and like all the other people here like
he knows what I've made this video and I
haven't done anything and you're like
yeah Rosen Crossing is great keep it up
I thought it was actually nervous to
talk to you cuz I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
just like this weird Asian kid here Oh
who's this like this guy looks this guy
looks like you know he made this action
movie you know just feel I gonna be like
too cool for me yeah and we make just
cheesy romantic stuff and here we are
nine years later yeah we both stuck with
it dude that I mean that video showed
that you guys had something different
from like that was that was a lot what
is it's actually do you watch that if
you cringe at some of the moments has it
held up in your eyes frozen crossing
ones more or less hold up there's
something a little bit of cringe frozen
crossing to is like cringe see the
follow up is just like too way too much
cringe because like it's a way to LA we
had a lot of like la people helping us
the second one and like it just becomes
like it's to LA like you mean that like
the production or the the acting is all
sticky and like yeah the production kind
of gets like it's it's the heavy cameras
on tripods so you know we're house
versus like out in like the snowy woods
of Minnesota with little camcorders yeah
so you're basically saying that the
Midwest has better you know actors and
oh my god
yeah I think the other thing here is
like if you watch any like Hollywood
like straight-to-dvd action pieces
usually just like shot of somebody
shooting cuts the shot of someone
getting a shot shooting and that's
that's what the majority of frozen
crossing to is however there's the one
scene in the middle at the breach scene
and I'm really practicing yeah we should
all go we should do a react video real
quick I don't know how what we're doing
on time but for the Wong foo fans at
least that might be watching this
there's a there's a short film a medium
film that we let you know at the time
cuz at the time in 2010 40 minutes was
lot like no one was making 40 minute
videos narrative mm-hm we made a thing
called agents of secret stuff is asked
with with nigahiga Ryan Higa who's still
going also and we shot if we shot
something like right here like as I was
walking I was like oh this is the
interrogation I was doing research for
that and I pulled it up not knowing that
it was shot here right and you're like
wait a sec wait a minute I recognize
that loading dock anywhere dude I I mean
a lot of people don't know but like cuz
yeah we had never done action before
that was our first action thing ever and
we're like okay we have to have gun
choreography we have to have fight
scenes and and we we call Freddy first
yeah yeah just moved here and like you
link he linked us up and you came like
to do all the karate like do all the
action like you know I don't even know
the proper terminology for what your
position was but you were overseeing
like all the action shots action design
action designer coordinate all this
stuff and then even when we were editing
you came in to like help us with the
editing like you came to our that was
our first office ever um out in Pasadena
and answer like Nico court of digital
has a very deep pitch and then we we
shot a bunch of stuff like in this area
to like that was such a cool time I feel
like it was like the first time that we
met creators that weren't just
personalities but that knew how to shoot
too and that we were learning from like
I never like I want to UCSD it was a
film art program but I never went to
film school so like there was there
so much technical stuff that I hadn't
I'm still don't really know but like
learning from you guys was like I was
like watching like oh this is film
school I was learning stuff so agent
secret stuff when that happened without
without corridor digital yeah yeah I
think you guys even had a channel at
that time yet huh maybe just started I
think we're just starting yeah we
launched corridor I think when frozen
crossing to came out wait so what you
said you had already moved to LA for a
year what were you doing for a year but
you wouldn't post on all kind of a
crappy monster on the bear one right no
no oh the bear one is one Freddie made
okay dark island dark island where can
we find organs variously called infected
out you can find dark island on amazon
wait it's still there i think so dude
and she have a watch party as you can
raise dude we should do you have one
here is it like is it ripped we have a
ripoff we have a poster in the bathroom
oh yeah yeah if you go upstairs there's
a poster up there oh my god humble
beginnings you know have to let people
know yeah and i would like to say that
the wasn't the rates or whatever from
harry potter like the black smokey
things that fly in yeah totally ripped
off our monster design oh you should
write a letter dear JK rowling yeah
screw you I'm sure she'll see that yeah
it'll affect your emotional yeah but I'm
glad that we're still going I'm glad
that you guys are still going and I'm
very honored to be on this podcast we're
honored to host yeah dude should we
start a podcast she long food started
pluck and I don't know if I can have the
hello you ever been you ever African
boba yeah yeah run man you're not gonna
have time for I mean yeah your your
equivalent your your equivalent of our
podcast is your boba show that's true
yeah that's true
wait I do have one final question like
to ask sure i hopeful hopefully it's not
a downer question oh because it might be
but i think it's pertinent because here
at corridor you know it's corridor
basically started as a partnership
between me Jake and Sam mm-hmm and you
had two partners when you started out to
this is the exclusive
and ted has moved on yeah I'm Wong foo
he moved on well yeah so if several
years ago you moved to New York yeah
with his wife yeah how would like
splitting up with a partner you know I
imagine it can't be easy mm-hmm and I
have no idea where you'd even begin like
navigating your way through some right
at that was it was it a thing that you
guys were like it felt all right and how
did that how did that play out yeah did
you how did you navigate through a
process like I mean Jake I'm not asking
because I'm on a okay there's a couple
things here and yeah I actually haven't
talked about this you know publicly with
a lot of people so I appreciate the
question actually um luckily you know
things weren't that messy just because
our paperwork from the beginning was so
bare-bones because it's this whole thing
started so organically and like hey we
should do this oh we have to file this
okay yeah let's go do this oh we have to
open an account okay let's go do that
you know so it was never like this like
sit down all right share shares whatever
equity whatever it was just very natural
so some would argue that because of that
that actually makes things more
complicated like there but I think
ultimately we value our friendship or
just want to be like not [ __ ] to
each other that we're like not going to
be too you know too precious or too
angry and anything like we the riding
was kind of on the wall like we knew
that Ted had already been living out
there and going back and forth for a few
years and you know he was already trying
to like take a back seat to certain
things and yeah it was it wasn't like a
surprise and we just kind of wanted the
first thing is like look in our grand
scheme of our life like let's not make
this one moment that is actually gonna
be like a sliver of time like too
detrimental so let's just get it done
get it done and over with and like let's
figure out like where we need to sign
let's do whatever distributions and like
let's just get over with
so luckily you know it was actually okay
in terms of like the technical stuff but
in terms of like you know emotionally I
think you know when you first start yeah
you're never thinking about like when
it's gonna like you know when things are
gonna like separate or when things are
gonna change you obviously want to have
like the best you know hopes and dreams
and everything and but yeah I think as
you grow older as long as you're open to
understanding that we are all individual
humans and that we're not trying to hurt
each other and that just like this is
just how my life developed so that I
have this new interest or then I that I
have less invested in this in this side
of like my life or project I think like
it's okay so it's really comes down to
like communication and honesty and and
being willing to for me also being
willing to like really be pragmatic
about things in like being okay to say
hey like yeah that that hurts my
feelings but like it does make sense you
know and when we were able to
communicate that where when I went if I
was able to like think about you know
the situation that way like it
definitely made things flow better I'm
not gonna say that it wasn't like oh
like this sucks or this is too bad but I
think the great thing is that ultimately
you know there is no animosity and the
fans are still supportive you know and
and it actually has allowed us to expand
and create new opportunities for others
so there was actually like a period of
time that you know yeah our identity has
fill Westhead three guys at
wongfuproductions I actually think
started to be a detriment where we were
to protect to protective or I was
actually too protective of we have to
maintain this image of the three of us
and so it made my expectations of like
hey you you know we should we should
have all been that that that one event
or why why didn't we you know come off
this way in this one video or whatever
and and even to like our interns or our
new staff like you know I wasn't
listening to their ideas because I was
like no no it's it's about the three of
us first and so now looking back I'm
like oh
or now looking at what it is now where
there's contributions from everyone and
and we're all working together and we're
all hearing different voices like to me
that's so much better than preserve this
image of only the three of us you know
and like and we're the boss you know
what I mean so I actually really
appreciate that you know we've been able
to you know grow actually since you know
Ted stepped away and yeah it's actually
been really really good you know and
healthy for us yeah I don't know like
that I think every channel you know is
gonna go through different changes
whether it's you know even like just
like how much mental bandwidth you know
we can give and it's also just like
we're just getting older like eventually
I'm going to have a child I want I want
to have a family and I I don't want to
have that much responsibility it's not
like it's not about like you know like
arguing about like I'm trying to
preserve like I need this responsibility
don't take my job away from me it's like
no please please someone take this
responsibility from me you know so it's
been good and and the team that we have
now what we've been training and
preparing them for a point where they
can take on a new response to be like
this so for the first time that just two
days ago they wrapped we shot a new
series seven part series same thing it's
gonna be about total running time maybe
like our forty five seven part series I
wasn't involved
oh really yeah I was just executive
producer they I helped on story and I
gave writing notes like the script notes
but we found Taylor was one of the
writers and we found another writer from
outside they wrote it together our
in-house ADR in-house production
coordinator in-house what editor a
cinematographer they all did it
themselves and we've been preparing for
that because we did you know yeah P last
year were like you know they were the
they took on the brunt of the work for
extended period of time and I was still
directing but now it's like okay I've
seen that you guys can handle this and
so they they finished and it's going to
be great and I'm and I showed up to set
like four hours late and I was like you
guys need anything and they're like nope
I was like cool go get some chicken
nuggets for you guys and I think that's
that's that's that's the beauty of
that's that's I think what you know I
want us to become like I don't think I
should be the only voice for Wong foo
forever anyways you know like and I'm
excited for for that you know I I joke
with them on like hey something like I'm
gonna willy wonka this and like you know
but yeah I'm really proud of them yeah
well well thanks for sure yeah for sure
I'm sure like I don't know like I what
we will talk about that later but like I
feel like you know you guys are creating
that same culture here too of like
really talented people that are fully
capable of taking on more and more as
it's already obvious you know like so I
mean we look we we watch you guys are
like dude like your corridor crew is
amazing you know so pops do you guys do
yeah everybody here on the team is very
essential to making what we make it's
not just one of us go out there and like
making it happen yeah yeah it's the Nico
show we get it this podcast is Nico
wanted to be like look I have the most
to say I'm the most important nice like
a big just painting yeah I just watched
the Rhapsody so I told ya you got the
Freddie mom for this apart and you'll
just have the Freddie Mercury Mustang
yeah you see it's the mustache
authorities like determines like
authority you guys need to make a video
about just like I'm like a mustache does
that give you a three because they do
give you authority I mean a lot of cops
have them so the other thing is is
actually perv like military haircut hair
code facial hair CODIS tree listen
you're not an NCO you can't have facial
hair unless it's of mush - that's that's
right here so you can't have them so you
can have facial hair but it's a and this
is different branches of military of
different rules but like the main rule
is like you can have a mustache and
that's it how did the mustache stick
around was it just because it's trendy
at the time when like world war ii
happened or what strike wait no that was
that was the first mustache ever no no
no I mean anyway that yeah yes I've been
trendy for centuries well I mean
Confucian times so yeah I mean I'll say
this like I don't know what it is in my
my own genes but I can't grow facial
hair on the side of my face oh this is
all cut at the same
okay right what yeah it's crazy yes a
natural goatee it is crazy and so maybe
it's that like more people could grow
mustaches some more people wore them
maybe it's just because we associate it
with cops and like the military
I want to fist like because like maybe
some people they can't control if they
go bald or not but they can control this
so like maybe that's like they're trying
to find that balance also maybe there's
that too maybe or maybe it's just people
are lazy and and if or actually like the
less you cut your hair that actually
showed more wealth because you didn't
not have this make sense and we just say
things yeah yeah there's gotta be a Vox
video about this yeah that's actually I
watched a lot of Vox I actually realized
that I'm the channels I'm watching now
are like like educational historical
documentaries or whatever like well like
the channels that ask like weird
questions like how many people could fit
in the Grand Canyon you know like how
like what is dark matter like that's the
stuff I'm watching them like yeah I'm so
not on normal YouTube that's what's the
step that like one or two people on
YouTube are there to learn something
yeah yeah it's I think it's even greater
than yeah
I just I just had to you know Google or
YouTube the same thing like something
about like installing a new fluorescent
ballast or something I was like I needed
to look it up no it's like that I think
it literally is like people just not
knowing things and sharing things yeah
we were gonna start a series called how
to YouTube yeah that's good oh I just
actually learned that I actually
searched how to make the cornhole game
oh because I want one at at our cafe we
have a patio and I was debating I'm like
dude it's just a board with the hole I
can make this I don't need to buy this
because I had like a hundred some bucks
yeah don't your money but I but I did
there are so many videos I gave like 5 a
try there like simplest way easiest
cornhole whatever and it still required
like huge tools and like guys like doing
like special type cuts or special type
drills to hide you know bolts I'm like
what is this just cut a hole in a 45
degree angle
setting like miter cuts and things on my
normal thing I really thought it would
just be like knee Okanogan Okanogan done
but it's actually a pretty complicated
situation over there so well they hit me
up next time all right I just I'm making
a guillotine right now so oh my god
hit me up the next time you need a new
set you have I'd be happy to makeup
that's awesome for for the bow bow shot
well I don't know I ended up buying one
for unfinished so it's so what we're
gonna paint it as unfinished for like 70
bucks okay that's that's pretty it's
pretty good right I wouldn't want to pay
you less than that anyways I would just
do it for the honor of having okay I can
sign it yeah sounds good next next round
okay thank you guys so much
yeah thanks for joining us yeah I um I
just have a big catch-up conversation oh
yeah this should be we shouldn't have to
wait for these but it sounds like it is
the last time we like we had a beer
somewhere but I think that was also
because of like work or something really
out of it yeah we should just uh we
should just hang out we're down the
street I'm like right here come to over
boba shut what would you guys be down to
do like a workshop on like like maybe
start your like do like a little lecture
on filmmaking V effects at the boba
shops I'd be down one of one of my goals
with the boa shop it's not just
obviously like yeah so but but like I
wanted to like be like almost like a
resource like where you know young kids
and that area is like an Asian Enclave
so like there's a lot of kids that are
growing up in families where it's like
you're not allowed to do anything
creative right like kinda like I was but
like to know that they can have a
destination where they can like learn
things about you know the creative arts
too so maybe we can add like a guest
speaker of Nico maybe cool have you lost
something down I'd love to do that dude
and well yeah well we'll set that up
it'll be your will be your first trial
of like that curriculum like played this
all you already have like where you
would start
yes I have an idea where I would start
oh my god oh my god you guys need to do
a parody or like a version of master
class you know like those videos yeah
yeah I'm like this is Nico Instagram
yeah they were going so hard for like
longer but like because they have other
writers and cinematographers and like
super famous directors Nico's
masterclass
you go I feel really bad advice well
presented 19 I know is for that yeah I
had a good time is everything you want
want people listening to check out I
mean if they're curious about our
channel and like our like if you want to
suck if you want to see court or digital
with romantic storylines and a few more
Asian people walk for days because I
apparently like you know what we are
everything you don't like about the
competition I'm ready for I'm ready for
the corridor romantic comedy guys it's
coming I think you guys said I can make
it like and still have your flavor in it
like there's I'm gonna pick you some
ideas for Valentine's Day next year or
some hang dad yeah like a romantic V
effects actually short it's not amazing
you guys do have you guys do have
romance in your short or your stuff
though to like like Master Chief doesn't
want to die you know you have like the
the nine Channing armor and you know you
have a emotional tension you know I've
seen lifeline I have seen hey well
thanks so much it's fine
just one episodes all okay hey how much
of single by 30 did you watch it bro any
do YouTube bridge you know the reality
is like the actual episodes on YouTube
bread get like 50,000 views oh my oh
yeah yeah yeah maybe a little bit more
yeah it's tough walk because they
weren't they renewed minefield season 3
they don't probably got good views but I
remember when I did well over that uh
like Logan Paul high school Hunger Games
video movie so yeah thinning which is
also Stephen King book yeah when that
came out so you can still actually they
didn't show the views on YouTube but you
could have access to views by using like
one of the other API is Sam's like I
wonder how many views are actually
getting on this movie they're like
80,000 no way yeah even with the free
trial well that was before the feature
okay so they probably just did the free
trial after walls like wow there's only
has like 80,000 years
I mean it was it was what it was so
maybe that's why ya sing what dirty we
did okay we did okay with ours I'm glad
but uh same thing didn't get can-can you
didn't get the renewal but it's alright
yeah we should have done a parent lis a
karate kid remake apparently that's
that's like their their uh that's a dog
and pony show yeah who would have
thought that hiring a bunch of old TV
executives to try to relaunch TV on
YouTube thanks guys I think so
well I hope you all enjoyed that a big
thanks to Phil for coming out and
joining us here in the corridor cast go
check out their YouTube channel at
youtube.com slash wongfuproductions and
once again just a little gentle reminder
for all of you guys interested in the
corridor digital geometric t-shirt and
the corridor digital iridescent hoodie
which is a wonderful hoodie I've been
wearing it everyday and I need to wash
it corridor digital dot store today is
the last day so get on over there if
you're thinking about it you will not
regret it because we have been really
making some pretty good strides in the
quality of our merch this year that is
it's some pretty good stuff heck I'm
wearing some merch right now I'm just
surrounded by merch it's all I would
have my that's all I have in my closet
these days but hey I'm stylin and you
can be too alright thank you for
listening everybody if you're watching
on the YouTube channel and you're not
subscribed consider subscribing and if
you want to find us elsewhere like on
Spotify and iTunes and all kind of stuff
we are there so you can find us there
it's so convenient in this modern age of
technology alright thank you see you at
the next one